we're looking at all of connected and
autonomous transport and really any
issues around that regulations safety
and the technology development in the UK
the projects that were often involved in
our demonstrators so we we start with
more controlled environments and sort of
build up to the real world but we've
been working on what we call pods small
self-driving vehicles that actually
traveled on pavements as well as roads
and we've really looked at how the pods
can be used as a platform for other
people to test on as well so that's what
we have here in the lab we've been
modifying pods and people can come and
try out sensors algorithms anything that
they are working on and they don't have
the ability to develop it all themselves
so at the moment there's an empty space
over there we are missing the pods that
happens to be here today we've got a bit
of a pub behind you what's the current
state where did you get to or where are
you at with these pods at the moment so
we demonstrated them using a control
system from Oxford University but we
have a interface that's open so that was
the Oxford system plugged in and now the
pods at the moment are in Bristol
working as part of the flourish
programme which is looking at
accessibility and user friendliness of
pods particularly for older generations
from a purely selfish point of view is
there gonna be a point where I can go to
the pub have two three beers and then
just jump in one of these and press a
button and go home
that is some people's visions certainly
and I guess the there's a different
levels of autonomy and with the pods
we're really looking at that end point
so what's usually called level 5 where
you don't have to do anything so as the
you've basically become a passenger
rather than a driver and so you don't
have any responsibility and for the
journey in which case whether you are in
a fit state or not is not important but
most of the vehicles and systems that
are coming out at the moment especially
in sort of traditional cars have some
level of responsibility still on the
driver so there definitely is the vision
of the future and there are some level
five systems in controlled environments
for example at Heathrow Terminal five
they have pods taking you to and from
the business car park they go sort of
within tracks but they're not not really
following the tracks that's more a
safety thing and but there you are just
a passenger so that could be the vision
of pods in what McKeen's one day with
the system we had originally there's
really three main computers so there's
one that's actually owned by the sort of
base pod and that controls normal things
in a car like lights and that kind of
thing but also has a safety
responsibility so if you have a control
system that you um put on top and if
anything goes wrong with that the pod
will come to a halt basically and and
then the control system the autonomous
control system is usually made up of
again two machines the kind of low level
and high level controller so the high
level controller is doing everything you
would expect in terms of bringing in
sensor data having the maps that it then
compares against and making decisions
and the lower level computer is taking
the command from that and doing a small
amount of sort of sense checking and
again if there's any issues that will in
in the case of the pods that low level
computer will make sure that the the
trajectory that you're following always
ends in zero so if it doesn't get a new
correct command it will just slowly
bring the pod to a halt unless the next
one says actually keep going at at some
speed we're in the center of Milton
Keynes we had a mapped area with certain
destinations that you could pick user
interface that was touchscreen so you
could choose where you wanted to go when
you went in and
long as you close the door because he
button satisfied the other safety
interlocks then you were in autonomous
mode and it would take you to your
destination avoiding any obstacles along
the way
the pods operate on pavements as well as
roads and they were intended to do this
kind of last mile journeys so they
travel up to 24 kilometres an hour but
they don't usually make it that far so
it's a bit faster than walking pace
usually but not not that much and I knew
what's safe to do depending on who's
around you mentioned the go on the
pavements which in the u.s. they call a
sidewalk what happens if they run into
pedestrian I mean I didn't mean
literally Ronettes pedestrians what
happens if if you come across
pedestrians yeah so the laser scanners
and cameras they're always looking out
for what we usually call obstacles ahead
and the past is being optimized based on
that so you can decide sort of how close
you feel comfortable going to the
obstacles but once you've said that then
the pod will try to go around and one of
the challenges in this kind of
environment is actually if you want to
follow behind someone at their speed
that's a different thing to just going
up to them stopping because now you're
close and then they've gone away so you
go again you can end up with a bit of a
jerky ride and the same if you end up in
a crowd but you want to keep progressing
through and that's one of the areas that
we started to think about was how
assertive to be in a no that's a problem
they've had with other self-driving cars
actually in America with stop signs
sometimes you need to actually assert
that you're about to go and that might
not seem always like the safe thing to
do but otherwise you might sit at a
junction forever so there's that
trade-off we also looked at various ways
of communicating with pedestrians so and
having a noise that was just sort of an
underlying noise as well as maybe some
sort of horn or beep and obviously you
could also actually have a voice asking
people to move
or something so I think you could do it
in a friendly way but that people would
still be aware that something was coming
up behind them and they might want to
move to the side often when we encounter
pedestrians particularly if they're come
on coming to the vehicle and they've
seen it they will often modify their
path as well to sort of go around it
even if they're on their phone or
something we'll just look up and not
really notices something different but
just avoid it so there's quite a lot of
behavioral science to go into sharing
environments where there aren't really
rules of the road this is a world apart
from Tesla autopilot 70 miles an hour on
a motorway do you think it still has a
place or should people be using bikes
and walking and stuff yeah so the the
pods definitely if you look at some use
cases they look like they might be
taking some journeys that you would
otherwise walk or cycle but it's really
about the overall idea of mobility and
options and in our case we're not
actually developing this as a transport
system necessarily we're just interested
in the technology and how the UK can can
develop it and but there is a whole
spectrum of autonomous projects and we
were also involved in some of the more
traditional car projects with the pods
we did a lot of safety work and
obviously with all autonomous systems
that's really the whole driver for
having autonomy and and we were looking
from the point of view of these
low-speed vehicles we often ended up
with coming to a stop being the safest
thing to do not all of the time
but most of the time and and there are a
number of sort of layer levels and
different computers on board which will
check each other and if anything is not
sending the right signals then there
will be a way to and stop the vehicle
yes with any machine learning system
you're worried about false positives and
false negatives
and in the case of the pods if you
stopped for no reason that's usually a
safer thing to do so as I said our
systems were erring on the side of more
safety being that you would stop if you
weren't sure of anything and but
obviously if you're on the motorway and
being autonomous then just coming to a
stop is not not the answer so a lot of
vehicle manufacturers are stating that
they will take the responsibility for
quite a lot of the issues if it's their
software in charge there there is
discussion of kind of a black box to see
who was involved and but the insurance
companies and our companies are starting
to move it more towards that product
liability in a way from the driver
responsibility and UK government has
consulted on that recently so it's
working progress and so that's all fed
instant future and done in real time and
all of that talks back to our HQ server
so where the pod is what's it doing when
we're running publicly we're going to
have all of the jobs coming through